what's going on people in this video
I'll be explaining part two of Attack on
Titans final season in around 10 minutes
or less in case you're new to the
channel last year I did make a separate
video breaking down the complete
timeline for part one so if you're
looking for a refresher on everything
then I recommend you start with that for
everyone else let's get into Attack on
Titan part two which kicks off with the
Marans invading Shanta the main goal of
this surprise operation was for them to
quickly steal the founding Titan hence
why both Porco and Rina tried to eat
Aaron whenever they happen to get the
chance on top of that you had hundreds
of armed marlean soldiers entering the
district by parachutes and their job was
to wipe out the scouts therefore
reducing the amount of protection that
Aaron had for a while this game plan did
actually work quite well with the attack
Titan struggling to handle two Titan
Shifters and an anti-titan cannon at the
same time this struggle directly led to
onyankopon begging Mikasa and the other
prisoners for assistance and in the end
Armen does convince them to help out his
sales pitch was that even though it
looks like has betrayed them to join
Zeke's side the reality is that Zeke's
plan to end the Elian race doesn't sound
like something their friend would agree
to for that reason armen's theory was
that Aaron is only using Zeke to
activate the founding Titan's powers and
once he succeeds in doing that he can
trigger a small scale rumbling which
should scare away their enemies for at
least the next 50 years the gang then
suit up and get ready to defend him but
by the time they arrive Aaron was
already receiving backup from the Beast
Titan the last time we saw Zeke he'd
blown both himself and Levi to pieces
with a thunder spear but thanks to his
Royal Blood privilege this random pure
Titan rebuilt his body by sacrificing
its own muscle Levi wasn't so lucky in
that he lost one of his eyes and a
couple of fingers however due to his
aimen blood he was at least durable
enough to survive now if you remember
back in part one of the final season
flock forced hanji to take them to
Zeke's location and when they finally
got there in part two Hani escaped down
the river with Levi's body while the
aorus brought Zeke back to Gan when they
got there the Beast Titan then used his
signature attack to crush a chunk of
marlean soldiers a chunk of Marian
airships and also rhina clearing a
direct path for Aaron to reach him the
two brothers knew that if they made
physical contact the founding Titan's
power would activate and so for right
now the aim of the jeras and the scouts
was to make that happen while Marley's
aim was to stop it happening above
everything else as the battle progress
Zeke was nearly killed by meat's
anti-titan Cannon and although the shot
wasn't fatal it put him in a a tricky
position where he couldn't defend arum
with his pitching assault this is what
gave Riner an opening to pin down the
attack Titan and so to save his brother
Zeke uses his scream to create a massive
distraction As We Know by this point in
the timeline there were hundreds of
people in chanta who'd been tricked into
drinking his spinal fluid including
pixus and Falco and by screaming he
turned every L one of them into a pure
Titan during the chaos Falco initially
tries to eat Rina before turning his
attention to Porco who kind of
sacrificed himself
and by eating gallad Falon inherited the
draw Titan simultaneously Aaron was
frantically running to make contact with
Zeke with help from con and Jean as well
but at the last second Gabby blasts his
head off with an anti-titan rifle if
we're being honest this should have been
the end of the whole story but by pure
luck Aaron's decapitated head lands
directly into his brother's hand what
this meant is that the founding Titan
had made contact with the Titan of Royal
Blood and as a result they were both
sent into the PA dimension
because time works differently in here
Aaron felt like he arrived almost
instantly whereas from Zeke's point of
view he'd been waiting here for what
felt like years that's why as you can
see his beard was looking a lot more
raggedy than usual however this never
would have happened if he' known about
manscaped right now mancate is offering
20% off plus free international shipping
on their beard Heder Pro kid which is
this all-in-one beard grooming solution
in case you don't know mancate is used
by over 9 million men around the world
and that number is only growing thanks
to the premium design and modern feel of
all of their products personally I've
been using the beard hedger for a month
and this thing comes with 20 different
length that are built in not to mention
it has a titanium coated blade that
feels as smooth as anything the beard
hedger is also Wireless waterproof and
it just feels incredibly light so you
can easily bring it with you if you have
to take an unexpected trip if you want
the beard Heder Pro kit for 20% off free
shipping and some free bonus gifts like
the scissors and the brush then all you
have to do is go to manscape.com /t
Quirk and when you're checking out just
put Turtle quirk in the promo code box
remember though this deal is for a very
limited time so if you're interested in
upgrading your current routine then now
is definitely the time to do it thanks
again to manscape for sponsoring today's
video and don't forget to use my links
specifically if you want to help out the
channel as well now moving back to part
two in the PA Dimension Zeke was
restricted in change due to the Val
announcing war and so it came down to
Aaron to control the Founder's power
back when the brothers spoke in Marley
they agreed that they'd use this power
to sterilize the entire eldian race but
just as Armen predicted Aaron never
wanted to go along with this instead his
real aim was to eradicate all life
beyond the walls ensuring that the
island would be safe forever and
guaranteeing the Historia won't need to
become a Titan shifter unfortunately for
Aaron Zeke had already suspected that a
betrayal might happen and so during the
long time he spent in this Dimension by
himself he learned how to override the V
announcing War to explain how it's worth
mentioning that 2,000 years ago a
creature known as the source of all
living matter transformed a slave girl
called Yia into the first Titan for the
next 13 years yir then served the eldian
Empire hoping that the king would show
her the kind of love that she wanted
since she was young although he never
did her soul continued to obey the Royal
bloodline even after her death and since
Zeke arrived here without his mind being
tainted by the will of K frisz he did
eventually manage to get her on his side
as a consequence the Founder's power
belonged to him speciic specifically and
he was only pretending to be restricted
so that he could hear Aaron's true
feelings despite being betrayed though
Zeke did still want to help out his
younger brother cuz you know he just
assumed that Aaron had been brainwashed
by their dad in the exact same way that
he was for that reason Zeke transports
them into their father's memories to
show Aaron the truth but what they
discover is that there was no
brainwashing and that Aaron is just
naturally the way he is another surprise
is that as they watched the memories
from the day gisha killed the Royal
Family Zeke finds out about the attack
Titan's special ability to put it simply
people who have the attack Titan like
gisha are sometimes able to see the
memories of future users of the attack
Titan like Aaron what this means is that
present day Aaron is able to communicate
with gisha from the past by sending back
memories from this exact moment using
this method Aaron gives his dad the
motivation he needs to destroy the royal
family and by doing so he sets the
entire story into motion when the
brothers then arrive back in paths Z
orders his slave to sterilize the eldian
people whereas Aaron speaks to Y as a
human being and offers her the
opportunity to end the world and free
herself from the P Dimension a tearful
yir then agrees to this proposal and in
the real world Aaron's head reconnects
with the source of all living matter
what follows this is all TI hardening in
the world coming undone hundreds of
thousands of Titans being released and
ready to trample the world and finally
Aaron transforming into this gigantic
monster although you could say the
scouts were expecting a rumbling of some
kind each of them did feel kind of
uneasy by the scale of what was about to
happen before they had time to really
think about it though there were two big
problems they had to address problem
number one was that all of Zeke's pure
Titans were now rampaging through chanta
and problem number two was the question
of what they should do about Falon given
that he inherited the draw Titan feeding
Falon to someone like pixus would turn
them back into a human from Connie's
point of view he was understandably more
eager to revive his mother who's been
like this for the past 4 years and so he
just nabs Falco while the rest of the
scouts were busy cleaning up Zeke's mess
Elsewhere on the island Levi and Hani
were on the run from the agas and in a
purely coincidental meeting they
approached Peak and maath to team up in
this scenario both sides did actually
have mutual interest considering that
they both wanted to kill Zeke and
neither of them wanted a fulls scale
rumbling to grow their Alliance later
that same night after all of Zeke's
Titans were destroyed hanji convinced
Jean and Mikasa to join them while at
the same time Armen tries to gain
Gabby's trust armen's belief is that if
the outside world is destroyed he
doesn't want there to be a second war
between the surviving Warriors and the
surviving Scouts earning Gabby's trust
is one step towards making sure that
doesn't happen and so the two of them
race to ragako Village to save Falon
from getting eaten ultimately they do
make it there just in time with Armen
heroically offering to sacrifice himself
instead of Falon only for con to swoop
in and save him at at the last moment
after some self-reflection Connie then
gives up on bringing his mother back
this way and he joins the group as they
head back to Shanina along the way the
four of them then happened to bump into
Annie aka the female Titan who was freed
from her Crystal the moment that Aaron
undid all Titan hardening since being
free Annie's only objective has been to
get back to her father in Liberia and so
to accomplish this she becomes the
newest member of the alliance finally
the last few people added to the group
are Rina onyankopon and Y and although
Yelena isn't exactly an ally maath
wanted to bring her along for tactical
reasons as you'd expect she's one of the
few people who knows the direction that
eron's likely going cuz she was the one
who taught him all about Marley and you
know the geography surrounding it the
next day the group then arrives at the
port and their mission here was to
capture the azimo flying boat and then
use it to get close to Aaron the issue
is that by this point flock realized
that the scouts had betrayed them and so
he gathered an army of jeras to take
full control of the port as if that
wasn't bad enough they also strapped
explosives to the Flying Boat itself and
had taken the asabo engineers as
hostages creating an incredibly tricky
situation for the alliance initially
Armen and Connie's plan was to trick the
aerus without needing to resort to
violence but the plan fails when flock
attempts to kill the engineers what
follows this is an allout war between
both sides with the scouts having to
murder their own friends to make sure
that the flying boat doesn't get damaged
the female and armored Titans then join
the battle as well and although the
engineers is saved they reveal that it
takes them half a day to get the flying
boat ready this presents an even worse
problem since protecting the boat for
half a day is quite literally impossible
when you have waves of jeras that can be
brought in one after the other in the
end kiomi proposes an alternate plan
where they set sail to the marlean city
of Oda where they can get the flying
boat ready without having enemies trying
to kill them although the downside of
this plan is that if they don't time it
correctly it's feasible that the
rumbling would trample them before the
boat is ready to fly regardless the rest
of the alliance agrees to this plan and
despite being outnumbered they brutally
tear down nearly all of the agis with
special help from Falco's jaw Titan
possibly one of the most surprising
things about this whole battle though is
Keith shardis making an appearance as he
blows up an entire Train full of flocks
reinforcements after that flock himself
is then shot down by Gabby while many of
the surviving jerish decide to run away
rather than you know sticking around and
getting their heads cut off by mikaza
the alliance then successfully begin
making their way towards Oda but not
before we get two extra deaths in the
port there was one other ship that could
potentially catch up to armen's group
and destroy their ship and so meath
stays behind to destroy it instructor
shardis also decides to join him and
this was a nice moment since shardis
used to think of himself as an
irrelevant bystander but here maath
tells him that if it wasn't for him
blowing up that train the alliance would
already be dead the two men then explode
as they detonate the last remaining ship
and with that the rest of the group is
able to escape now flashing back one
year you're remember that in part one of
the final season Hani proposed that the
Scout should take a trip to Marley so
they can understand the enemy in the
final episode of part two were then
shown exactly what happened during this
trip and what the scouts found was a
world that was even more hostile towards
ens than they originally thought on the
flip side though there were also good
people who didn't deserve to be squashed
by the rumbling and during this trip
Aaron struggled to decide what exactly
he should do years earlier when he
kissed his story's hand he saw visions
of the rumbling and knew it was likely
going to happen but there was one
specific moment where he almost deviated
from that future that specific moment
came on this trip when he asked Miker
about her feelings for him cuz in this
moment if she had told him the truth
then he was prepared to walk away from
the future he saw however for better or
worse she family zoned him setting into
motion a chain of events where he left
the Scouts in infiltrates Marley meets
up with Zeke and does everything that
led up to the current moment on the boat
to Oda Mikasa wonders to herself what
would have happened if she'd given him a
different answer while at the same time
in another part of Marley aon's Army of
Titans wipes out a Global Alliance of
military ships and tramples an entire
city full of people to dust with that
said that was part two of Attack on
Titan the final season in around 10
minutes or less and if you enjoyed this
video then don't forget to like And
subscribe especially if you don't want
to miss my recap for part three until
the next one peace out